so now for the other team the Los
Angeles Lakers we talked about it a
little bit before the game they won the
inseason tournament the first that
they've ever had in the NBA I asked you
Isaiah was this an extended hangover so
now it's extended even further can we
still blame the inseason tournament at
this point well it's it's not a blame uh
but it it's a matter of intensity and
concentration going to that level and
then as Channing pointed out now you got
to come back and get in tune with the
regular Seas
and sometimes your your your intensity
level and your body level it's not
matching up with the way the rest of the
league is playing and I I think right
now you know the Lakers got to find a
way to get back to that intensity get
back to that level of concentration and
then the key word can they sustain that
level of intensity and concentration
every single night as opposed to going
up and down with it Channing you played
with LeBron and you shared with us about
the difference playing when he's not not
on the floor and when he is on the floor
what does this Lakers team have to learn
to do in the absence of LeBron James
well then two people you're replaceable
I know
that and they would I would tell you
firsthand look and that's the thing
they're playing to get minutes and to
get this LeBron is playing to be the
greatest player ever in to win
championships so if you are consistently
not showing that you can get better the
Lakers have two big glaring holes one
they are atrocious at shooting threes
and if you if anybody knows anything you
need to be a shooter to play with LeBron
or a playmaker yeah so ad and Braun have
shown that they can win with this
formula if you don't fit into that
formula you got get them bags start
start getting ready because other
players can do those things so for me I
need the Lakers to either Buy in or be
ready to move on and I think for me also
they play too slow yeah they play too
slow you cannot play the same when you
have LeBron on the court as you do when
you're in that second unit I like you
know obviously Austin Reeves had a
pretty solid game turn the ball over a
little too much for me they're not
generating enough easy baskets right
driving kick driv and kick drive and
kick and sometimes you're going to have
to shoot shots that you're not
comfortable with because it's the right
shot also 17 turnovers for 20 I think it
was 22 assists you can't win that way
you're not even giving yourself a chance
to shoot the ball at least at the
backboard uh but it can't it be fixed
maybe but they need some shooting they
got to find somebody goodness so to some
all up they need some
shooting say the Sho they just they need
yeah yes yes they needo a lot of
shooting let's check